це найважчий час для роботи бо воно
краще було би можливо перепочити але я
думаю Я думаю що це дуже важливо те що
ми робимо тому що ми маємо блискучих
дискутантів сьогодні на
нашому діалогу і першого Я хочу
запросити Петра коржевського поки буде
Петро йти то я ще раз представлю бо мої
в ефірі може не всі його знають але
думаю що всі знають хто займається
професійною освітою тому що Петро 16
років просіння у світі він був
заступником е-е директора Департаменту
управління освіти Рівненської відповідав
за розвиток професійної освіти пізніше
ми його знаємо як заступника міністра
який перший реалізував цей проект і
вибирав пілотні регіони і зараз і зараз
маємо можливість як директор
Департаменту освіти Рівненської
військової обласної військової
адміністрації реалізовувати певні речі
ти бачення яке було так що вітаємо
Оплески Петрові
ближче до мене але давайте ми в цьому
порядку будемо Друга людина Я би сказав
що вона дуже легендарна друга людина -
це є Людмила Комісарова Заступник
директора Департаменту освіти і науки
Миколаївської військової адміністрації
це людина яка
8 місяців під обстрілами керувала освіту
Не тільки професійною але й керувала
всією освітою е-е Миколаївської області
е-е як самому казала 7х24 це була правда
Тобто вона не виїжджала під ви з ми
бачили що робиться в Миколаєві вона
постійно була працювала і розвивала так
що прошу привітати Людмилу е-е Олег
паска директор Департаменту
освіти і науки Львівської обласної
військової адміністрації це та область
де є найбільший у нас учнів професійної
технічної освіти де є дуже багато іннова
інших рішень І взагалі освіти Львівщини
прямо скажемо воно найкраще правда Олег
Володимирович бо я там теж працюю чому я
так кажу прошу не ображатися іншим
регіонам і
і
дискотека до нас доєднається Вікторія
болюта молодший радник впровадження
реформ проекту реформ професійної освіти
проекту нашого проекту в Європі Union
fuskills
Дякую вам вітаємо Вікторію
колеги я вже теж з математики і ми
поміняємо арифметику на на кожне питання
буде вам по три хвилини Я буду це
пильнувати за тим часом щоби було Більше
питань І ще я хочу відразу оголосити що
ми ж є в онлайні і колеги які нас
дивляться в онлайні вони можуть задавати
питання в чаті І ми тоді будемо їх
озвучувати і те саме колеги які є в залі
ви теж Є асистент який має збирати якщо
піднімати руку і я скажімо
занести задасте питання тобто Оце є такі
правила гри тому я звертаюся до до Петра
от Гуру нашого професійної освіти от з
вашої точки зору от прошу назвати три
позитивні спеціально до позитивні зміни
тому що негативних ми маємо дуже багато
три позитивні зміни які сталися в
системі професійної освіти от зараз ми
звузимо в вашому регіоні а потім як тому
що і українську сказати бо ви знаєте
я прошу взяти мікрофон насправді
перше що вдалося і дуже мені це хотілося
аби проаналізувати дві системи
професійної освіти системи фахової
передвищують щоб для себе принаймні
скласти враження які ж управлінські
рішення кожній із них як у системі яка
формує трудовий потенціал треба приймати
друге нам все ж таки вдалося
створити позитивний Імідж професійної
освіти
напрацювати комунікаційну стратегію яку
не встигли презентувати вишка в нас
випередила вона презентувала
комунікаційну стратегію але ми її
сформували і вона стала ключовою і
справді про професійну освіту говорить
всі Ну і
важливе вдалося модернізувати систему
професійної освіти принаймні через ті
регіони які попали у відбір і ми пішли
не вузьким шляхом 7 центрів професійної
досконалості а широким фронтом
21-двало 19 так і рай
Ну по ходу через війну тому що окуповані
Це дуже добре тому що ми покрили хорошу
географію і дали можливість про
професійну освіту чути на всій території
України Дякую вклався в одну хвилину
поаплодуємо за це зробив аплодисменти
Людмила це ж саме питання до вас
я акцентую увагу мабуть на останніх
роках під час військової агресії тому що
ми доказали перша - це дуже позитивна
такий момент ми доказали собі доказали
всім доказали те що про в тих освітяни
це кагортаце еліта з усіх галузей освіти
тому що Знаєте Легко голотувати коли
немає що їсти але коли з Миколаєві
миколаївщик регіонів виїхало більше
502% населення і ми виконали регіональне
замовлення не набагато на 80%, то я
вважаю що це подвиг моїх колег Я вважаю
те що Снігурівка яка була під окупацією
і ми кожну дитину знайшли вивезли цю
дитину знайшли з ней зв'язок і дали
можливість І доказали що це і є у кожної
дитини право на освіту На Це теж
маленький подвиг моїх освітян І хочу
сказати що ми попри в вересні місяці
більшість закладів працювали наживо і це
теж наша наша досягнення в профтехосвіті
Дуже дякую Оплески теж Бачите я казав 3
хвилини тут хвилин вкладаються Дякую вам
це направду тому що ви знаєте що
Миколаївській області принаймні на 1
вересня Минулого року я не знаю як зараз
11 11 будівлі були знищені 11 заклади
про снігурівку ми взагалі мовчимо І ще
зараз і підтопили крім того всього що
цієї біди міркувало так що дуже дякую
вам дійсно це героїчна робота яку робили
ваші люди під вашим керівництвом Дякуємо
Олеже прошу позитивні зміни адже перші
три позитивні зміни які приходять мені
на думку перше ми запровадили чітку
систему критеріїв оцінки роботи кожного
закладу відповідно до кількох там семи
простих показників і тільки на основі
цієї системи ми ухвалюємо управлінські
рішення друге - це те що Нам вдалося на
основі
висновків зі стратегії запустити систему
промоції закладів профтехосвіти і
професійного і освіти і це нам дає те що
ми кожного року вже третій рік поспіль в
нас набір постійно зростає Якщо я не
помиляюся Ірина Володимирівна Ми перші в
Україні по набору
Я просто хотів вас залучити до дискусії
і третє
враховуючи цей рік в нас є дуже серйозне
розуміння і увага до професійної освіти
з боку керівництва адміністрації то я
вам зараз назву цифру яка вас шокує це
майже півмільярда гривень в кінці цього
року буде за останні три роки в систему
професійної освіти Дякую
в нас представлені регіони Зараз
панікторі я вам слово дам я не так як
попередниця мені не дали Я вам дам я вже
це пережив сам цю травму от тому
нас різні регіони тому що
Людмила представляє регіон і я вже
говорив які під обстрімо що затоплений
дуже важкі вони цю війну відчули ну
повністю на всі 100% регіон Львівської
області і Рівненської це фактично ми
більше відчували роботу щодо вимушено
внутрішньопресованих осіб і я хочу
сказати Те що подякувати всім директорам
Яким є і всім хто працює професійній
освіти так як спрацювали в перші місяці
війни професійна освіта не спрацювала ні
одна галузь освіти повірте мені це ви
заслуговуєте дійсно цих аплодисментів І
от те що сказав Олег е-е паска про ці
інвестиції вони є зароблені роботою
директорів і не тільки директорів там
були постійне чергування і всіх
працівників і тоді побачили що оця сфера
професійного світу вона є важлива і Вона
страшенно спроможна Просто ми її не
бачили і от оця біда ця війна вона
проявила потрібність і спроможність цієї
сфери Вікторія ви бачите всю Україну
от от ваші щоб ви мо Оцю що змінилося
значить з точки зору позицій з людини
трошки збоку яка не є в системі освіти
але дуже багато працює і робить для цієї
системи професійного світу прошу вас
Добрий день шановні колеги партнери
друзі Дякую за запитання і говорячи про
ті позитивні зміни які сталися в сфері
професійної освіти то в першу чергу все
ж таки хочеться сказати про підтримку
діджиталізації професійної освіти
Оскільки було проведено дуже багато
численних заходів спрямованих на
розвиток
цифрової компетентності викладачів
закладів професійної освіти України
студентів також долучилися ми до
оновлення офіційних веб-сайтів
веб-сторінок закладів професійної освіти
наскільки мені відомо близько 120
веб-сайтів було оновлено також
близько двох тисяч викладачів закладів
професійної освіти пройшли навчання
задля опанування цифрових навичок і
цифрової грамотності також було
обладнано 27 it-кабінетів що значно
спростило роботу і перехід навчання в
онлайн формат ще з часів ковіду ковідних
часів і коли почалася повномасштабна
війна в Україні повномасштабне
вторгнення це значно спростило перехід
на онлайн навчання
учнів закладів професійно-технічної
освіти також Хотілося би ще окремо
згадати це підтримка впровадження
компетентнісного підходу було розроблено
досить багато курсів як для керівників
закладів професійно-технічної освіти для
менеджменту для викладачів для учнів
зокрема
навіть в житті які стосувалися відбудови
так званого рибілдінгу де можна було з
різними спеціальностями проходити
навчання і опановувати нові знання
також було з нашої сторони проект досить
сильно долучився до того аби
закуповувати і обладувати
інтерактивні кабінети тобто були
інтерактивні панелі закуплені
3d-принтери інше обладнання планшети
ноутбуки що також досить суттєво На мою
думку позитивно вплинуло вплинуло на
професійно-технічну освіту в Україні і
також ще хотіла окремо наголосити на
тому що
було досить багато роботи зроблено на
шляху промоції професійної освіти в
Україні
зокрема є промоція в тих же соціальних
мережах досить популярних серед молоді
та взагалі створення ефективної мережі
центрів кар'єри проведені тренінги
навчання для фахівців які працюють цих
центрах і
також ще окремою такою вже хотілось би
підкреслити окремим словом це проведення
психологічних сесів регіонах які досить
ефективно себе зарекомендували і в
майбутньому теж на перспективу також
бачиться що ці заходи будуть досить
ефективними вже і на жаль Коли ще триває
війна і післявоєнний період теж вони
будуть досить ефективними дякую дякую
вам
бути
ми не плескаємо тільки тим хто не
укладається в регламент всі решта треба
обов'язково плескати зараз Вікторія вам
не буде питання але я хочу запитати
керівників
професійної освіти які ну фактично два
керівники оці всі освіти але ми сьогодні
будь-що І говоримо Ми говоримо про
постійну освіту
ви представляєте пілотні регіони
Рівненська Миколаївська Львівська
область вони були в тих 7 яких е-е Петро
відібрав разом з Іриною
колегіально так вдвох Так я жартую
от в мене таке питання
скажіть дві речі перше е-е щоби ви
відзначили той якраз Вікторія розказала
багато речей Що зробимо Дякую вам е-е от
те що ви отримали бо ви знали дизайн
проекту і Ви перший хто реалізовував цей
проект будучи засновником міністра який
відповідає за професійну освіту і друге
на що було От більше очікування від
проекту Ну може не очікування але
скажімо в певних обставин які вони
змінилися щось не відбулося А ви е-е
чогось дуже хотіли щоб мало бути бо ви
проект як ніхто добре знаєте прошу Дякую
насправді дуже добре що ми не
дотримувалися дизайну від старту до його
фінішу впродовж чотирьох років проект
гарно змінювався був гнучким і Це дало
можливість залучити максимальну усі
заклади професійної освіти України тому
що те що відпілотовувало воно зразу
маштабовувалося Ну я для мене це дуже
важливо ми зайшли ви разом з плюсом про
який ми ніколи не мріяли зараз почалися
обміни і це той позитивний тренд який
професійній освіті якраз робить її
інвестиційно привабливою ми маємо своїх
якщо ми говоримо про нову українську
школу і там є своя Агенти змін то
професійній освіті через цей проект теж
появилися свої спеціально навчені люди
які отримали певні знання які розуміють
що таке центр кар'єри які розуміють як
проводити профорієнтаційну роботу як
залучати піднявся відсоток залученості
дітей по завершенню навчання в закладах
загальної середньої освіти в заклади
професійної освіти Ми про професійну
освіту почали розказувати як про
заклади який дає можливості будувати
власну освітню траєкторію Це ті
позитивні речі які є Звісно що не
вдалося не вдалося Ну були дуже такі
хороші наміри щоб всі чотири
країни-партнери долучилися до того аби
ми могли провести візитаційні
провести обмін стажування це те що не
вдалося але воно не вдалося не тому що
країни-партнери цього не хотіли тому
тому що на цей проект пішла пандемія
потім війна і десь і десь це реалізована
частково хотілося звісно щоби десь
більше
було контенту цифрового Бо якби не
пандемія його би в принципі не було От
тому що пандемія змусила нас належним
чином організувати
дистанційне навчання для професійної
освіти це абсолютний виклик але тут
спрацювали центри
навчально-практичні центри про які там
всі до яких всі спочатку ставилися
скептично але потім виявилося що це ті
місця які дають можливість пройти
виробниче навчання виробничу практику і
можна було отримати документ державного
зразка тому в проекті дуже багато
позитиву але ключове навчання упродовж
життя - це не страх уже в закладі
професійної освіти і м'які навички для
викладачів і всіх працівників закладу
професійної освіти це вже норма бо ми
завжди хотіли Харків ми хотіли щоб нам
привезли трактора екскаватори і так
дальше але ми до цього не знали як
керувати трактором як екскаватором Тому
тепер ми розуміємо що треба брати м'які
навички треба вчити Персонал це якраз є
формування людського капіталу От коли ми
сформуємо людський капітал все решту те
що там буде даватися для практичного
його втілення воно вже у людей є Я
вважаю що проект абсолютно успішний і я
теж Як Іра каже я би теж тут поставив
кому От і думаю що тепер уже з цією
кількістю людей які залучені були у
цьому проекті всі наступні проекти вони
будуть абсолютно масштабніші і треба
намагатися залучати до проектів більшу
кількість людей і регіонів Дякую вам е-е
Ви дуже важливі речі сказали дуже
важливі речі сказали тому що книжка пише
що зміни можливі тоді коли є позитивні
практики є Агенти змін і це фактично
підтвердження слів віри Рибак про
інституційну зростання конституційного
спроможність системи професійної освіти
в тому числі і завдяки
і завдяки цьому проекту
Людмила це саме питання до вас
Яка місія після Петра Миколайовича
говорить то дуже важко тому що наступне
поміняю
тому що те що він говорить Це дійсно
вірно це є великий позитив хочу сказати
тільки доповнити вірніше про той Джекпот
якби в проекті отримала Миколаївська
область Я не говорю зараз за матеріально
тому що дійсно цей освітнє середовище це
І як ви говорите обладнання для
сільського господарства на яких ми потім
і навчалися дійсно працювати і навчати
своїх учнів адже тут був в тому що
в рамках проекту ufuskills ми на цілий
тиждень це Джекпот для Миколаївської
області Ми поїхали обмінюватися досвід у
на до Львову і цілий тиждень ви вивчали
досвід своїх колег ми ділилися цим
досвідом своїми позитивами проводили там
майстер-класи це знаєте досвід це така
школа дорога якщо б ми продавали цей
досвід за собівартістю Мабуть ми стали
мультимільйонерами і якби це було
запроваджено десь на рівні держави то я
думаю це був би позитив а нам це був
Джекпот От юфікіс і все що сказав Петро
Миколайович Я приєднуюся добре дякую
дякую вам
Людмила дуже важливе питання дала оці
горизонтальні зв'язки розумієте чим
відрізняються як кажу совдепія від
демократичних е-е речей при які завжди
говоримо там є вертикаль а у нас дуже
важливий горизонталь коли ми працюємо
командами коли ми всі ці речі робимо
коли ми обменського ми пізнаємо і тим
самим ми об'єднуємо країну тому але з
Володимиром вас згадали
про цей добре речі які ви зробили прошу
ваша думка
чи мікрофон вночі будь ласка От так все
це робила і робить велика команда але
кузьмичу А що стосується цього проекту
фоскілс А є три речі які би хотів
сказати перше
він привернув увагу до професійної
освіти ще більшу увагу
Може хтось запитає Ну і що що привернуло
увагу а Справа в тому що ми з вами
живемо в епоху боротьби за увагу людей
Чим більше ми привертаємо увагу людей до
певної проблеми тим більше в людей є
знань про цю проблему А що відбувається
якщо в людей є більше знань про цю
проблему раджу почитати вам Українську
Правду статтю Івана Вакарчука пам'яті
повторюваність подій
власне Іван Олександрович тоді в цій
статті обгрунтував математично Що Чим
більше інформації в нас є про якусь
проблему тим швидше коротше яцикли
відновлення і розвитку
тієї чи іншої галузі Ну він говорив про
контексті історії і державотворення але
це те саме стосується профтегати чим
більшу увагу ми привертаємо до системи
освіти тим швидше вона розвивається і це
є ключовий напевно
ключова функція і ключова заслуга цього
проекту
Дякую
попри те колеги
проблеми лишаються і виклики також
лишаються І що роботи є дуже багато тому
що далекі до ідеалу от уже ви будете
тоді почнемо тоді з Людмили
Людмила Скажіть будь ласка от які ви
бачите виклики вас дуже багато викликів
тому що ви специфічний регіон який
зазнав дуже великих втрат от які ви
можете сказати виконати більше сказати і
це цікаво так виклик на нашій
миколаївщині про те що у нас дійсно ви
бачили Павлу кузьмовий чи Ірина бачила
наші заклади які постраждали Це перша
відбудова цих закладів ми повинні
відбудувати їх попри все друге е
катастрофічно Я думаю у всіх нас про в
тих освітян не вистачає кадровий голод
особливо майстрів виробничого навчання
особливо з тих професій де
таких важких професій де людина
підприємстві може отримати велику
заробітну платню і наш майстер такі
копійки і утримати цю людину практично
неможливо у нас в закладі це і
десь у нас на миколаївщині є проблема з
передачею майна і постає питання щодо
капітальних видатків тому що для того
щоб отримати капітальні видатки потрібно
заводити в програму наші заклади тому
проблема передача майна теж У нас це як
виклик сьогодення це і
повернення бізнесу на миколаївщину тому
що ми працюємо для роботодавців ми
працюємо для бізнесу і у нас на
сьогоднішній день більше трьох тисяч
підприємств Вони
пошкоджені або зруйновані а повернення
бізнесу це є теж Рука допомоги і
співпраця з роботодавцями це і можливо
[музика]
більше хотілось би
повернення
хоча дійсно ви зараз сказали Олег
Володимирович про те що зараз є таке
проблема є і на нас звертають велику
увагу ми дійсно про себе проговорили всі
знають що І хто це про в тих освітяни
але хотілось щоб на місцевих рівнях теж
було ще більше акцентувалося на це увагу
Ну Зрозуміло Коли я говорю про бізнес я
буду говорити про дуальну освіту воно за
собою це все підтягує Ось такі у нас
виклики але їх дуже-дуже ще багато це і
створення навчально-практичних центрів
якісь на миколаївщині дуже мало І знову
потрібно на рівні держави мабуть
підтримати ці навчально-практичні центри
Я говорю про свій регіон що ми не
зможемо
оновити матеріально-технічну базу якщо
не буде допомоги від держави це дійсно
так
Дякую лише Володимир чи прошу вас
на нашу думку є наступні три ключові
проблеми професійної освіти перша
проблема - це є кадри це працівники в
закладах професійної освіти і ця
проблема Мені здається стосується всієї
системи освіти середньої освіти в тому
числі друге - це є проблема управління
от ми з вами дискутували Павло Кузьмич
про як управляти там академічними
ліцеями прирівнює управління і якщо
академічні ліцеї мали би бути на
регіональному рівні якщо ми хочемо
якість освіти той професійні ліцеї мали
бути на регіональному рівні тоді можна
цією системою якісно управляти це це
Друга проблема
і третя проблема
це над якою ми вже почали працювати Це
те яка вона характерна і не тільки для
професійної освіти для середньої освіти
це вона тягнеться від прузької школи оця
без ініціативність учнів і власне
система різних конкурсів підприємництва
винахідництва це те що ми намагаємося
зараз розвивати для того щоби учні які
закінчують заклади професійної освіти
могли не тільки йти працівниками на
якесь підприємство але й могли самі
створювати не боятися створювати і
ризикувати створювати свою власну справу
дякую дякую
прошу
ну найбільшою проблемою Звісно це буде
післявоєнно відбудова і в контексті
професійної освіти Я хочу звернути увагу
на те що
регіонального замовлення і фахівців з
регіонів буде недостатньо для того аби в
інших за рахунок здійснювати певні види
робіт це означає що повинен бути
змінений перелік професій
загальнодержавного значення з
урахуванням того який об'єми і масштаби
відбудови будуть в Україні і це
надзвичайно важливо тому що ну не можемо
ми врахувати зараз на регіональному
рівні скільки фахівців і зрештою нам і
не дасть місцева Влада здійснювати
підготовку тих хто за аналізом ринку
праці ну справді для регіону не є в
такій кількості потрібен другий ключове
для професійної освіти
ключовий для професійної освіти виклик
це
[музика]
підійти до 27-го року до старшої
профільної школи з розумінням
законодавчої нормативно-правового
забезпечення яким чином ми будемо
відбирати дітей у заклади за професійним
і академічним спрямуванням це має бути
надзвичайно важливо це не може бути за
рівнем академічних знань або за якимись
там ЗНО яке можуть запровадити після
дев'ятого класу це мають бути ті скелеті
навички які дитина хоче розвивати вона
їх хоче розвивати Досліджуючи там в
академічному напрямку чи вона їх хоче
розвивати бо вона хоче в майбутньому
стати інженером і через систему
підготовки робітничих кадрів Вона має
таку можливість також треба розуміти що
якщо ми не створимо маркерний Центр
професійної досконалості першої Україні
Я так розумію що він випав на нашу долю
і його треба створити саме таким щоб усі
інші заклади професійної освіти розуміли
як вони мають виглядати це має бути
мультипрофільний заклад який має мати
сучасний освітній простір сучасне
технологічне обладнання там мають бути
висококласні фахівці А взагалі для
висококласних фахівців і те все що всі
кажуть що не вистачає кадрів це неправда
не вистачає як зараз це називають
політичної волі оплатити працю таким
чином щоб вони з'явилися тобто даєте
заробітну плату 30 тисяч гривень завтра
в закладах професійної освіти працюють
висококласні кадри вони дуже швидко
відновлюються вони дуже швидко
навчаються і вони абсолютно адекватно
можуть готувати для ринку тих фахівців
які є ми зараз говоримо що в нас
наприклад є 43% дітей які після
завершення навчання у закладі загальної
середньої освіти обирають заклад
професійної освіти Я не бачу проблем
щоби стало 50%, але це має бути спільне
рішення на рівні регіону що ми для себе
як регіон бачимо
офіційно привабливим якщо до нас будуть
заходити бізнеси ми маємо бути готові їм
дуже швидко готувати кваліфікованих
робітників Якщо за це будуть платити і
це буде додана вартість для регіону і
тут же знайдуться кошти для того аби
здійснювати оплату праці але якщо вона
на національному рівні не буде
врегульованою ми не зможемо її
виплачувати тобто тут ключовий виклик це
нормативно-правове забезпечення якщо ми
не приймаємо закон про професійну освіту
у цей період часу у час війни у час
можливостей дальше ми його просто ніколи
не приймемо дякую
Ви заторкнули дуже важливі питання
по-перше дійсно от ці центри
досконалості те що ви казали казали оці
позитивні практики показати моделі як
має бути це може бути у нас тобто не
обов'язково що це було інша країна деякі
Я думаю ми їх маємо ці центри
досконалості які ну принаймні години
точно знаю е-е сміється Я думаю ви
знаєте про які я думаю які я знаю які
знають вдосконалювати
попри те проблеми ви назвали Олег
Володимирович Я знаю що прийнята
програма розвитку освіти Львівщини і є
там певна частина яка стосується
професійної освіти і ви вже озвучили ці
великі суми тому що я пам'ятаю В 16-му в
17-му році коли от була перша державна
субвенція на створення
навчально-практичних центрів то там було
всього-на-всього на всю Україну 50 млн
ви тут назвали так суму значно більшу
від тих 50 то є на одну область
Розкажіть будь ласка як Київ є плани як
піднімати як робити що плануєте у
Львівській області будь ласка дякую пане
козловича А цього року Ми планували на
навчально-практичні центри 10 млн але
коли ми звели в одну таблицю всі заклади
всі навчально-практичні центри всю
логістику яка є в системі професійної
освіти
то і потреби які є прийшли на нараду до
голови і нам додали ще 30 млн коли ми
допрацювали вже всю документацію
цифра станом на сьогодні це 53 мільйони
це на навчально-практичні центри таких
навчально-практичних центрів до цих 40
що є ще буде створено 13 крім того до
тих 200 мільйонів які були на ремонт
гуртожитків які були в жахливому стані
приміщенні це ще цього року плюс поза
100 мільйонів тому я і сказав що за
останні три роки це величезна сума і але
ця сума коштів вона не просто так
з’явилася а тому що напевно ключова річ
була зроблена була перевернута завдяки
всім вам і Міністерство Дякую Ірина
Володимирівна що приїжджаєте до нас Пані
Оля дуже вам дякую за ті форуми за це
все І власне ця увага до професійної
освіти вона зуміла переконати
багатьох людей
що профтег освіта важлива і тому зараз
нам набагато легше працювати в системі
професійної освіти Ну і крім того
звичайно директори закладів роблять
велику роботу і оця система
рейтингування яка в нас є вона не
стільки для покарання стільки для
стимулу для аналізу значить комусь треба
допомогти Можливо десь треба оптимізацію
провести і тому воно все працює А зараз
в нас є амбітна ціль Ми з 1 вересня
запускаємо навчати розпочинаємо навчання
і сподіваюся що Вже наступного року десь
січень лютий ми зможемо презентувати
систему автоматизованого управління
професійно-технічної освіти Львівщини
Дякую
Людмила прошу ваші плани які є плани
Миколаївській області там складніше у
вас Зрозуміло Тому що я перепрошую
таких сум на навчально-практичні центри
немає
Мабуть це залежить не тільки а від
кожного регіону від його бюджету у нас
на превеликий жаль зараз немає таких
коштів і
дійсно нам важко говорити про перебудову
і про оснащення
матеріально-технічної бази Ось але А у
нас плани амбітні тому що ми вийшли із
стадії очікування Ми зрозуміли що бути
стадіоні очікування і чогось там
тремтіти боятися Це не про нас і ми
розробили
закладами розробили свої стратегічні
бачення стратегічні цілі кожен заклад
розробив ми зараз над ними працюємо до
25-го року і
сподіваюсь вони будуть втілені
допрацьовані Я хочу сказати що дійсно
Петро Миколайович сказав що навички це
Євро валюта Колись я почула від нього
току фразу дійсно нам Є над чим
працювати Тому що
для того регіональне замовлення нам
зробити зараз дуже важко Я вже говорила
про той відсоток який виїхали за
межамиколаївщини і на превеликий жаль
зараз тільки повер відбулося 10-15%
населення і
Але я думаю що формування контингенту
дорослого населення це перепідготовка це
ціна і мікрокваліфікації це є над чим
працювати за коротку терміновими цими
курсами ми будемо над цим працювати це
зрозуміло і безпека нашого наших освітян
і це бомбосховище які потрібно знову не
маючи коштів потрібно зробити їх і
якимсь чином от так от виходить що всі
Гум допомоги багато проєктів Вони якось
знаєте хоч ми заявили про себе
профтехосвіту ми говоримо хто ми такі
але в першу чергу говорять ні
профтехосвіта в ці проекти не підлягає
Ні ми її обходимо тому що тільки зараз
це направлено йде для загально загальної
освіти тому Ну важкувато
хочу сказати що у нас Ми однієї з п'яти
областей які перемогли в свій час те що
в конкурсі я размус плюс Петро
Миколайович і зараз
фінансова підтримка фінансова програма
підписана і наші 15 учнів вони в вересні
місяці плануються зараз проводяться
курси і психологічні там мінімум
тренінги з цими учнями вони будуть
направлені і відвідують такі обмін
студентами це вперше на миколаївщині я
про це говорю І горжусь з цим не чуть
в Гданськ комплекси в школу морських
комплекс морських шкіл Ось і це саме з
тих професії які технічно складні Ну ось
у нас такі плани
хотілось би сказати що можливо тут на
рівні десь держави я говорила
неодноразово але ще така проблема це ми
говоримо часто про інклюзію Але ми не
розмежовуємо десь в інклюзія і спец
контингент спец-групи і хотілось би десь
на рівні держави
говорити або нормативно чинним
законодавством затвердити саме Які діти
вірніше з яких професій ми можемо
навчати в спеціальних групах не
інклюзивних групах
продумати знову щоб штатних розписі у
нас були вихователі асистенти це дуже
складно на сьогоднішній день ми
керуємося нормативними забезпеченнями ще
за часів Гороха
Дякую дійсно коли ми звіриною
володимирною об'їжджали регіони то
питання інклюзії системи офіційної
освіти доволі складне тому що лікарі
дають ну казали колеги дають довідку що
може освоїти професію але насправді дуже
важко освоїти професію і дуже важко
конкурувати на ринку праці цій людині з
особливими ну з певними функціональне
обмеженнями як ми зараз говоримо ті які
він існують це перший і друге звичайно
розумієте
Львівській області і легше тому що дуже
багато військових частин зареєстровані у
Львівській області і це ПДФО який йде
від цих мобілізованих від
солдатів які зараз в наших захисників
раді завдяки яким ми Тут спокійно
спокійно можемо говорити і очікувати на
перемогу Вони повертаються в область
тобто оця система податкова вона робить
дуже різні
по податковій спроможності області і
Львівська область виграла Я не знаю
наскільки Рівненська але Миколаївська
точно знаємо що там досить великі
проблеми тому тут якоїсь такої
справедливості насправді насправді немає
пане Петре е-е от Як у вас
відбувається у вас з бюджетом області
все газ є профіцит Ну якщо говорити про
військових то ви знаєте що західний
оперативне командування власне зараз вже
не у Львові а в Рівному
із військовими справді
є дуже великі проблеми в частині якій
просто ті територіальні громади які не
вміють справлятися з бюджетом вони на
них отак кількість військових які яка
появилася в кожній громаді вона ще
отримує і реверс тобто Кошти які треба
запланувати так аби видатки з
потребами співпали або не було реверсної
дотації бо потім коли військових не
стане коли бюджет недоотримує того
об'єму коштів прийдеться повертати
реверсну дотацію А це вже буде потім
коли військових не стане і тому тут
Зараз ми працюємо з громадами в частині
того аби навчитися планувати бюджетувати
аби прогнозувати і це Ну з бюджетом
насправді ніяких проблем немає і є ще
інше щоб я хотів звернути професійну
освіта Вона має
бути таким навчальним середовищем для
бізнесів ми що два тижні Зустрічаємося
на такому майданчику Рівне warcup з
усіма бізнесами які є в Рівненській
області і в тому числі із релакованими і
запитували йому їх кожного разу про те
Які у вас є проблеми От і ці проблеми
стають загальними проблемами для всього
регіону для влади регіону тому що влада
хоче отримати а білий бізнес хороший
надходження хороші можливості і якщо цим
інструментом правильно користуватися то
дуже можна отримати багато Ми пішли
шляхом створення кластерів ну від
it-кластера деревообробний кластер зараз
іде кластер агровиробництво ви знаєте що
ми якби країна справді Агро і якщо ми
цим не скористаємося що таке Агро це
означає що просто виростити продукцію
замало цю продукцію треба сертифікувати
супроводжувати Або можна її було продати
на зовні ринок щоб її продати на
зовнішній ринок там дуже багато
запобіжників тому що кожна країна
бореться за своє за свого
товаровиробника і тоді коли ми зуміємо
перенавчити людей що бізнес треба ввести
знанням То коли ми скажімо Я як той хто
проводить тренінги до мене підходять
люди після тренінгу як кажуть Якби я
сину 20 років назад коли я започаткував
бізнес мав такі знання де б я зараз був
про що ми говоримо бізнес немає належних
знань так ті великі компанії які мають
хороший менеджмент Вони уже мають знання
але бізнес - це не обов'язково великі
компанії і цей бізнес неефективно якщо
це тільки великі компанії тому що якщо
його не диверсифікувати то якщо падає
великий підприємство це означає що зразу
стає великою проблемою і Німеччина і
Британія мають по 68% податків від
малого і середнього бізнесу і він тому і
диверсифікований тому власне систем
професійної освіти має бути
законодавцем моди ведення бізнесу
законодавцем моди якщо ми це не
усвідомимо у нас не буде в майбутньому і
тому я проти класифікатора професій який
зараз є ми маємо мати професійні
стандарти освітні програми ми маємо мати
національну рамку кваліфікації привести
її до європейської тоді не стане змагань
з тими хто старший хто ми сьогодні якраз
п ворошкевичем на цю тему говорили якщо
ми зуміємо це все належним чином
організувати нормативно і законодавчу в
нас є майбутнє Дякую дуже важливо ви
сказали що треба Ну відповідно щоб був
бізнес треба і підприємництво вчити
наших учнів щоб вони могли робити
стартапи що вони могли створювати свої
фірми а не тільки бути найманими
працівниками тому що господарі завжди
господарі тоді планують що тоді робиш І
тоді ти можеш мати ці бізнеси Вікторія
ми вас не забули ми знаємо що ви з нами
присутні і ми цьому дуже раді от
от Які би от ви вважаєте Працюючи на
проекті знаючи систему професійної
освіти От такий би так е-е радили
зробити кроки нашим керівникам
регіональним в яких напрямках треба було
сфокусувати щоби розвинути краще
професійну освіту наше в Україні або в
Україні в цілому тобто що вам ближче
Дякую Дуже за ваші запитання
саме закладів професійної освіти і з
роботодавцями оскільки за з періоду та й
мабуть до періоду початку війни в період
поки триває війна ринок праці - це
взагалі досить динамічна Така річ він
змінюється і ті спеціальності які були
до війни актуальними вони можуть бути
неактуальними після війни тобто Все
змінюється і дослідження наприклад ті ж
соціальні Дослідження які проводяться
серед роботодавців які визначають
вимірюють які в них запити Вони все одно
повною мірою не розкритого що дійсно
потрібно про це до роботодавцю
працедавцям і Відтак все ж таки
вбачається такою великою необхідністю
зблизити максимально заклади професійної
освіти з роботодавцями крім того не
забуваємо про те що досить багато
бізнесів було релаковано з
регіонів які розташовуються в східній
Україні на Західну Україну І тому да
дійсно це така На мою думку досить
важлива річ про яку не варто забувати
встановлювати зв'язки з виконавцями
зрелокованим бізнесом також дуже важливо
і дуже актуально це все ж таки є
проведення короткотермінових курсів для
в тому числі для дорослого населення та
для внутрішнього переміщених осіб
оскільки це вже зараз і після закінчення
війни
роботодавцям потрібно буде робоча сила
досить швидко і кваліфікована і разом з
тим не забуваємо про досить великий
сегмент людей які не зможуть На жаль
працювати за тими спеціальностями які
вони працювали до війни їм потрібно буде
набувати нові навички нові спеціальності
тому такі короткотермінові курси вони ну
видаються дійсно дуже актуальними і дуже
важливими і також Ну звісно в житті
напрацювання які є в проекті
ці знання ті інструменти було би дуже
добре аби вони втілювалися
впроваджувалися наприклад
за напрямом оцінювання на основі
компетентностей і так далі тому звісно
саме на мою точку зору на мою думку ці
такі три мабуть основні речі які би я
виокремила зараз Дякую Дуже дякую вам
аплодисменти Вікторія
колеги я не бачу пана Володимира чи є
питання тих колег які є в онлайні якщо є
Якщо є зараз Віра якщо є питання тому що
ми пам'ятаємо і дуже вдячні ті хто є
разом з нами не В цьому залі а вони є в
онлайні немає запитань так вчать і не
було Добре тоді
чи є питання залу то мав асистент
збирати якщо ні можна підняти руку я
бачу першу руку панірі будь ласка
питання в загальні даєте чи до когось
е-е конкретно хай кожен відповідає
правильно Хай всі працюють я за
а мікрофон Я даю
я придумав давати взагалі буду бігати
Дуже дякую
[музика]
за панельну надзвичайно цікаву дискусію
пане Петро комплимент відчувається
національний рівень регіональний рівень
і досягнутий баланс у мене питання
такого плану пам'ятаєте як ми
кілька років тому всі хотіли зробити
аудит І ми його зробили і ми думали що
ми оптимізуємо систему профтехосвіти
відразу після того як отримали
результати аудиту пройшов час коли є
прийняла відповідне рішення ситуація
змінилася звичайно
але як ви бачите відбудову це особливо
стосується пані Людмили відбудову
зруйнованих шкіл з огляду чи дійсно
потрібно відбудовувати кожну я розумію
всі ці людські моменти і так далі чи
потрібно дійсно відбудовувати кожну
зруйновану школу чи потрібно трошечки
подивитися
звичайно про так Я наразі говорю про
професійне Про професійні про школи
професійної освіти профтехучилища Я
наразі говорю я не говорю про середню
освіту Так це до вас питання Ну і
можливо воно стосується всіх інших в
меншому екстенті але
стосовно оптимізації воно звичайно
стосується всіх друге питання У мене до
пана Петра ви У нас Флагман це вже всі
визнали
Скажіть будь ласка коли Ви говорите про
кластери
Це щось таке що стосується смат
спеціалізеш Так ви були по-моєму Пілот
на область яка розробляла стратегію от
було б дійсно цікаво з точки зору обміну
досвіду по-перше А по-друге з точки зору
наступного проекту Skills for Recovery
почути
відповідь на ну дуже коротку дякую
Дякую я прошу коротко відповідати бо я
думаю що є питання ще взагалі щоби дати
можливість
Людмила по-перше
щодо оптимізації Миколаївській області
Ми почали оптимізацію в 20-му році
створили робочу групу і потім я теж член
робочої групи по оптимізації коли ми
працювали із своїми колегами Ми з 31-го
закладу Ми вирішили зробити 22 заклади
на сьогоднішній день У нас по
статистичним даним у нас 31 а як до
юри-де-факто у нас працюють 24 заклади в
стадії реорганізації тому що в минулому
році продовжили цю реорганізацію і два
заклади у нас теж були реорганізовані в
цьому році ми теж продовжуємо
реорганізацію і з тих шкіл Як ви
говорите із наших закладів профтехосвіти
які пошкоджені у нас один заклад під
питанням тому що в плані оптимізації
вона повинна бути об'єктивно і виважена
і зрозуміло що тут логістика в першу
чергу теж відіграє роль і зараз і
на часі ми вирішуємо питання щодо Чи
буде функціонувати Цей заклад чи є
доречно його відновлювати чи ні всі
останні заклади які у нас пошкоджені
вони підлягають відновленню я зрозумію
що це дуже великий ідуть і асигнації
фінансові і якось будемо вирішувати
сподіваємося що будуть якісь програми
відновлення але те що ми вже провели
оптимізацію продовжуємо її це у нас таке
є один тільки заклад під питання всі
останні ми будемо відновлювати Дякую
перед тим як Петро
на питання після того що дійсно
українська області там немає жодного
закладу якому би було Менше 300 300
учнів
натомість натомість Миколаївської
області ну з тими даними Ще й володією є
вісім таких закладів А у Львівській
області
скільки у Львівській області був в мене
тут так воно виходить що десь порядка 15
але їх 49 тобто Там набагато більше
кількість закладів ніж одного і в
другому Тобто це питання складне але от
як з тими кластерами бути
дуже добре розуміли що якщо ми не підемо
шляхом смарт спеціалізації не зробимо
професійну освіту розумною не зробимо її
технологічною не оцифруєм її то просто в
нас як невеликого регіону достатньо
фінансового ресурсу ніколи не буде ми
пішли цим шляхом ми навіть більше того
ми пішли цим шляхом за межі області Ну
до прикладу знаєте компанія m-tac яка
відчуває Ну в цьому одязі ходять усі від
президента там от і ми їх познайомили з
едельвікою волинською яка робить полотно
те яке з якого можна там Вибачте всю її
продукцію відчувати і не треба це робити
в Китаї Тобто це теж якби є така Ну
такий контентний проект аби люди
розуміли хто чим займається і аби свої
обігові кошти не використовувати бо не
може так бути оце в нас була така До
речі наска проти інституційне
протистояння було між службою зайнятості
і професійною освітою кожен собі хотів
слідкувати найкраще обладнання і в
кінцевому результаті хто виграв програла
держава тому що вона і одним і другим
давала ну умовно там якісь ресурс тоді
коли зрозуміли що вони шукають ми вчимо
Це абсолютно нормально і тоді ми краще
вчимо вони швидше шукають От і тут смарт
спеціалізація - це ну це це ну справді
для невеликого регіону це можливість
вийти на Абсолютно інший технологічний
рівень ви ж Бачите як змінюється
технології як там умовно за ними
встигнути не можна і там підприємство
легкої промисловості який буде займатися
і розкроєм і пошиттям швидше за все що
це нерентабельно хтось буде займатися
розкроєм хтось буде займатися пошиттям
рівно так само як деревообробні Є певні
коопераційні речі ми там маємо умовну
компанію кроноспан не тільки ми вона є
там і на Волині і ми як заклад
професійної освіти Беремо субпідряд на
виготовлення там умовно палет бо всі ці
речі рятуються палєти це Вибачте мені
нарізати дощечки збивати з них це це
людино-годинно затратний виробництво
заклад професійної освіти може це робити
в три зміни залучивши учнів залучивши
майстрів і отримати додану вартість от
якщо це якщо ми підемо цим шляхом
професійна освіта буде актуальною її
треба актуалізувати про неї треба
говорити як про освіту можливостей якщо
ми не запустимо навчання упродовж життя
професійна освіта теж буде з обрізаним
контентом тому що просто ППП цього
замало для того аби утримувати державі
такий заклад А якщо держава передасть на
місця то на місцях теж будуть стогнати
тому що вони неспроможні утримувати А
таку велику кількість таку мережу і з
такою маленькою наповнюваністю каже
Павло Кузьмич вартість навчання в
закладі професійної освіти повинна бути
дуже високою якщо ми хочемо хорошої
якості але тоді перфективною але то
невисокою через золото щоби не було по
300 10 по 300 А треба щоб був один три
тисячі ну от як Дякую
колеги
так будь ласка там я бачу дею мікрофон
але тут камер може ви Підійдіть
запитання до Вікторії
згадували систему оцінювання чи вважаєте
ви діючу систему оцінювання в системі
профтеховільна
Чи хотіла би ви мати кваліфікованого
робітника який встановлює
вікна вашому домі на 7 балів на 6 на 5
чи система оцінювання мала би бути вміє
робити або не вміє дякую
прошу коротко Вікторія Дякую Дуже за
ваше запитання все ж таки моя точка зору
в тому щоби оцінювання було на основі
компетентностей якщо ми говоримо про
професійну освіту тобто знання
теоретичні Це добре але потрібно теж
підкріплювати ці знання практичними
навиками що вміє фахівець робити І от
саме на це мабуть я би ставила і акцент
пане оболонька немає чи Юрій ришківець
хоче
щось з цього приводу сказати чи ні
тоді прошу
національна агенція кваліфікації робити
центри кваліфікації вимірюється
національна бо пан Петро підняв сказали
тут двічі було сказано національна рамка
кваліфікації
не знаю чи товариство звернуло увагу Бо
я такий трошки чутливий до того от е-е
пан Павло і пан Петро говорить
професійна освіта пані більше говорили
професійно-технічну освіту от В мене є
перше питання чи професійне і
професійно-технічна це синоніми чи ні і
супутнє питання от є національна рамка
кваліфікації де визначення рівні
підготовки фахівців так от в професійній
освіті які рівні ми готуємо чи в
професійно-технічній які рівні ми
готуємо щоб ми знали як нас співставити
з Європою зі світу Дякую
пане Петре Я думаю це треба вам
відповідати А хто хоче з колег може
ми говоримо про пон професійної освіти і
навчання я би взагалі хотів щоб це була
професійна освіта і щоб це була єдина
сфера єдина рівень третій четвертий
п'ятий Я думаю що це наші більше нам не
треба і цього буде достатньо кожен
заклад собі має вибрати якому рівню він
буде пасувати яких фахівців він буде
продукувати я не думаю що всі мають
готувати на третьому на четвертому і на
п'ятому Я думаю що хтось може готувати
тільки на третьому і на четверту і цього
буде достатньо Я про те щоб ми мали
швидкий випуск щоб ми нікого не залишали
там Бо він має навчитися поки аж ми всі
години всіма не вичитаємо і не отримуємо
належну заробітну плату тут треш трішки
треба підійти по іншому
Я думаю що тоді би і не стало питання
про те там фахова передвищення чи
професійна Це була би єдина система
професійної освіти яка би мала єдині
типи навчальних закладів ну для мене це
професі йний коледж тому що це було би і
привабливо з точки зору того як на
артикулюємо до суспільства що ми
говоримо професійний коледж От і мабуть
би я не встиг
[музика]
так зробити щоб так сталося але я ще
живий і сподіваюся що так сталося до
того як це буде дякую
Дякую чи є ще питання Ні по одному
кулуарах
маю право то тільки ті хто в єврокомісії
хто проект притягують може два задати
інші по одному а колишнє заступники
можуть
аплодую тому що сказав пан Петро дуже
жаль що Ви того не реалізували а щастя
що ви ще живий маєте енергію але питання
тут зразу так буде чорти всі в деталях
як нам так би мовити вирішити цю
проблему що на третьому четвертому рівні
ми готуємо за професіями А на п'ятому за
спеціальностями бо якщо ми все це
об'єднаємо в професійну освіту нам
потрібно якимось чином це зінтегрувати
як ви це Бачите
коні не робив це там розширено я би
зробив там скажімо як можливість а
підзаконним актом аби врегулював
Чи хочете щось додати Ні я не вас
народних депутатів заступники то колишні
А це діючий народний депутат
колеги наш час збігає якщо дуже хтось
хоче задати питання То прошу підняти
руку бо я не бачу ні праворуч ні ліворуч
якщо є якщо питань немає то давайте
попробуємо підбити підсумки наші
дискусії насамперед давайте подякую
нашим чудовим дискутантам прекрасні всі
були виступи Я вам дуже дякуємо І
скажемо так професійна освіта і освіта в
надійних руках в нас є Віра і на цьому
шприків згадував фестиваль Ну а на Віра
є Віра так і віра що буде більше так е-е
коли коли говорили що значить перемога
дискутували міністр з головою комітету
освіти і науки Сергієм бабаком то казала
перемога буде тоді коли ми всіх дітей
всіх наших учнів повернемо в Україну е-е
в тому числі Я розумію що короткий
термін навчання е в системі професійної
освіти але безумовно нам треба стриміти
те щоби наші громадяни поверталися в
Україну цей дуже важливо а з тих що
речей які звучали Я дивлюся для народних
депутатів є багато роботи тому що
по-перше є одна професійна освіта і я
думаю це ви теж поділяєте бажано щоб е-е
230 хоча би 230 народних депутатів
поділяли цю думку друге що говорила як
Володимирович Він говорив про те що цю
фрагментацію міста області воно теж не
Тобто ми маємо ніби дві фрагментацію
професійної освіти перефахову передвища
професійна і друге ми маємо міста
обласні центри і області Тут також
бажано було зробити третє що в законі
Про все що говорили статус е-е майстра
виробничого навчання Тобто його треба
визначити тут не може ця людина мати до
зарплату не бути Ну педагогічним
працівником не може бути бо немає
педагогічної освіти але час роботи і
інші речі треба певним чином прирівняти
законодавчим це зробити бо інакше Як не
буде зарплати ми ми не знайдемо людей а
далі І останнє висновок ми маємо
прекрасних керівників тому що згадаємо
Ірина Володимирівну суміксує Яка теж є
лідером цього всього руху Я думаю ви
командно все зробимо і вище доживете До
тих змін Я вірю все дякую
[оплески]
дякую вам дуже
шановні учасники
Я прошу вас
запрошую вас до нашої третьої сесії
діджиталізація та її роль у розвитку
професійної освіти
займайте будь ласка місця і ми
розпочинаємо
Доброго дня шановні учасники я щиро Рада
вас вітати на нашій третій сесії
ми розпочинаємо
Отже почнемо з організаційних моментів Я
хотіла би представитись я модеруватиму
сьогоднішню сесію №3 ді-джиталізація
Мене звати Ганна сухоцька і я хотіла би
почати з деяких організаційних та
технічних моментів
наша дискусія буде умовно поділена на
дві частини і перший блок нашої дискусії
стосуватиметься успішних рішень у сфері
діджиталізації освітнього процесу
а другий блок нашої дискусії буде
висвітлювати питання стосовно
майбутнього
майбутніх кроків у впровадженні
дідужилізації Отже
хотіло би
спочатку висвітлити актуалізувати нашу
тему діджиталізації Це надзвичайно
важлива тема яка ввійшла абсолютно в Усі
сфери професійно-технічної освіти в
усіх ланках саме тому ми сьогодні
розглянемо діджиталізацію з трьох
перспектив а саме з адміністративної з
методичною та з педагогічної точки зору
саме тому я хотіла би запросити наших
спікерів
зустрічайте будь ласка пан Олексій
Ситник аплодисменти
[оплески]
пан Олексій Ситник
є старшим проєктним менеджером напрямків
децентралізація
управління та цифровізація професійної
професійно-технічної освіти команди
підтримки реформ Міністерства освіти і
науки України
панцетник координує роботу та і
імплементує проєкти цифровізації в
директораті профтехосвіти
наступний наш спікер Це пан Андрій
Литвинчук Оплески будь ласка зустрічаємо
пан Литвинчук є першим заступником
директора державної наукової установи
інститут освітньої аналітики є членом
команди з розробки та впровадження
ведмес спільно з гарно нагадую гарно це
урядова установа яка перебуває у
підпорядкуванні Міністерства освіти та
науки Естонії
пан Андрій займається загальною
координацією проєкту зі сторони
реципієнта наступна наша спікерка - це
пані Наталя Рибак зустрічаємо
пані Наталя є заступницею директора
навчально-методичного центру
професійно-технічної освіти у Львівській
області пані Наталя розробила 11
інтерактивних навчальних курсів для
загальнонаціональної платформи
профосвіта онлайн для 5 професій
наступна наша спікерка це пані Даша
жагіна координаторка з питань навчання
ТОВ Omnia
Education partnershipes то в омні
зустрічаємо будь ласка пані Дарину
є членом
є членом фінського консорціуму на чолі з
національною агенцією освіти Фінляндії в
програмі UFO Skills пані Даша займалася
підтримкою та організацією тренінгів та
навчання в рамках нашого афінського
компоненту програми і остання наша
спікерка пані Ганна Ткачук
аплодисменти будь ласка зустрічаємо пані
Ганну пані Ганна є викладачкою
Вінницького міжрегіонального вищого
професійного училища які є флагманом
освіти входить в сотню найкращих
закладів освіти
про втихосвіти України і саме Цей заклад
спеціалізується на іт-технологіях
отже
як я вже сказала
діджиталізацію ввійшла абсолютно в усіх
ланки системи професійно-технічної
освіти і завдяки програмі ufcquest та
нашим міжнародним партнерам Польщі
Фінляндії та Естонії розроблена
десятки різноманітних освітніх проектів
та впроваджено дуже багато різноманітних
інтерактивних курсів Отже
нещодавно два тижні тому
у Львові відбулася конференція під
назвою впровадження реформи
професійно-технічної освіти ДВ пане
Олексію розповідали про новітні цифрові
інструменти Скажіть будь ласка які на
вашу думку є
найважливіші найуспішніші рішення з
точки зору Міністерства освіти у сфері
мобілізації пане Олексію будь ласка мені
треба похвалитись Добрий день всім
може здати що я тут в мене буквально
хвилина технічна технічна інформація від
себе може здатись що я тут дуже впевнено
себе почували це неправда Я хвилююсь і
єдине що мене тішить що більша частина
обличчя в залі це знайоме обличчя ми з
вами всі вже можна сказати добрі друзі
це була перша половинка мого меседжу а
друга половинка така що склалась добра
традиція що десь Як Мене запрошують на
якусь велику сцену і коли ця сцена
транслюється десь в інтернеті чи ще десь
у когось і з добрих друзів день
народження І я так от з'їдаю 30 секунд
часу і вітаю цю людину якби щоб вона в
телевізорі себе побачила я Івану написав
щоб він включав і дивився Отож сьогодні
день народження у пана Івана пикуса
начальника відділу там у нього багато
відділів але зокрема і відділ професі
йно-технічної освіти Львівської обласної
державної адміністрації Ваня привіт З
Днем будь ласка нашому імениннику
Хай у тебе вдається Ти великий молодець
і зокрема ти мені крепко допомагаєш
просувати проекти діджиталізації в
Львівській області ще раз нюхаю будь
крепкий
і тепер хвастаюся з моєї точки зору
найважливіші три проекти які ми
реалізували
протягом 22-го року Да і впроваджуємо їх
в цьому році їх рівно три та три просили
значить перше ми зробили і зараз активно
впроваджуємо електронний вступ практично
з 1 липня діти отримають документи про
освіту матимуть можливість вибирати
навчальні заклади Відповідно ми дали
можливість тим хто
тимчасово як там переселень абревіатура
внутрішня переміщеними особам тим хто за
кордоном тим хто з безпекових чи інших
мотивів немає можливості
дійти зі своїми паперами до того закладу
які себе вибрати для навчання ми зробили
можливість подати документи в
електронному вигляді через електронний
кабінет вступника є дебом естонські Мої
колеги найважливішим проектом вважають
проект еміс це модуль професійної
технічної освіти для ікону про нього
більш детально розкаже Андрій оскільки
він прям дуже залучений в цей проект і
третій проект який ми теж робили мабуть
ідея мабуть ще з 20-го року Тобто ми
його довго будували ми будували будували
і нарешті побудували платформу
професійна освіта онлайн Ми її
презентували в кінці Минулого року 23
грудня зовсім з маленькою кількістю
курсів Там їх було всього 29
активно залучаємо партнерів і так далі
до створення нових освітніх матеріалів
колег залучаємо і станом на сьогодні вже
курсів у мене тут зі мною більше того аж
ціла спеціальна людина в директораті
з'явилася яка займається тільки
освітніми матеріалами це Аня Бондар
Привітайте і будь ласка Привітайте будь
ласка пані Ганну
значить 80 Да у нас сьогодні вже курсів
і ще по-моєму 19 в розробці чи може там
трошки більше одним словом вже зараз ми
плануємо що в цьому до кінця цього року
тобто Вважайте 23 грудня ми вийшли
вийшли в світ люди і курсів було 29 до
кінця цього року ми плануємо більше 110
Звичайно це дуже мало але якщо
подивитись скільки Ну як це як
триволосини да Багато чимало так само і
курсів багато чи мало з точки зору
професій коли їх більше 300 треба
навчати за більше ніж 300 професіями
стокусів це мало але якщо ви подивитесь
на наповнення кожного із них скільки там
навчальних матеріалів і який він цей
навчальний матеріал і скільки роботи
перероблено щоб цей курс з'явився то 100
курсів це дуже багато це от прям
дуже-дуже багато От такі мої три
відповіді вступ еміс
професійна освіта онлайн Дякую пане
Олексію за дуже грунтовану відповідь на
наше запитання і я все ж таки хочу ще
одне питання вам дати які можливості дає
діджиталізація для управління та
адміністрування системи профтехосвіти
Ну давайте тоді
так само по трьох пунктах я спробую цей
раз коротше тому що попередній раз їм
часто так значить з професійної освіти
онлайн це зрозуміло це доступ з
будь-якої точки світу до сучасного
освітнього контенту Тобто де б дитина не
була контент україномовний ба більше ми
зараз стикнулись з тими хто виїхав за
кордон
вони побачили у нас там наприклад
матеріали там для
деревообробки і вони не ну не можуть
знайти в тих країнах Куди вони поїхали
Таких вже освітніх матеріалів за
безкоштовно тобто от наша платформа вона
дає матеріали всім дітям безкоштовно а
там за гроші тобто
платформа - це доступ до сучасних
освітніх матеріалів з будь-якої точки
світу це дуже важливий Я вважаю далі
це облік це
аналітична інформація це можливість
приймати в англійській мові є Evidence
bass-менеджмент управлінські рішення на
основі актуальних даних Тобто ти бачиш
що відбувається в системі Ми плануємо
якраз от ми зараз ми вчора вчора було
позавчора А ні вчора Вчора ми
проговорювали розвиток цього проекту і
ми
в цьому році впровадимо зріз
відображення даних відображення
дашбордів там можливо графічне різне але
для різних зрізів для Міністерства для
департаментів освіти щоб кожен на своєму
рівні управління бачив саме ту
інформацію яка йому допоможе прийняти
правильне рішення і
ну тобто е місце для
[музика]
управління системою і електронний вступ
Дуже просто Це доступність освіти це ну
якби можливо можливість дитині де би
вона не була вступити в заклад
професійної освіти вибрати подивитись А
можна все посмотреть вот можно все Да
можна всі заклади всі їхні пропозиції
які вони пропонують тільки професії і
так далі не на яких рівнях освіти все
тепер тепер всі рівні освіти
в єдиній державній базі з питань освіти
в єдеба все в кабінет в кабінеті тепер є
для всіх рівнів
Дякую пане Олексію
Пане Андрію ось
пане Олексій згадував неодноразово
систему адміністрування еміс Розкажіть
будь ласка покроково як впроваджувалась
як розроблялась дана система які її
переваги і як
і чи виникали у вас певні виклики чи
можливі якісь були ризики особливо що
стосується захисту персональних даних
Доброго дня колеги Мене звати Андрій
Литвинчук Я перший заступник директора
інституту освітнього аналітики наша
установа є певним бек-офісом
Міністерства з питань великих масивів
даних збору адміністративної звітності
формування аналітики і пропозиції на їх
основі для знову ж таки як сказав
Олексій
е Evidence basemaking прийняття
управлінських рішень на основі доказових
даних Якщо говорити про сферу
професійно-технічної освіти то якось так
сталося об'єктивних причин що
Вогник цифровізації він запалювався з
країв ішов з вищої освіти і шоу з
дошкілля загальної середньої і десь
посередині шляху він зіткнувся на сфері
професійно-технічної освіти що ми мали
на вході ми мали на вході
те що є потужна єдина державна база з
питань освіти яка вже наповнена
реальними якісними верифікованими даними
з іншою з іншої сторони ми мали
базу даних історично
адміністративної звітності яка щороку
подається закладами
професійно-професійної технічної освіти
і акумулюється можливо з використанням
показників дещо застарілих Але тим не
менше говорити про
відсутність цінності показників які
містяться в затверджених канонічних
формах звітності не можна тому
міністерством було і поставлено завдання
продумати забезпечити автоматизацію
управління
освітою з використанням
автоматизації класично відомої освіти
яка називається еміс Education
менеджмент information System тобто дані
збираються від респондентів через
каскади верифікації в реляційні детальні
бази даних національного рівня в тому
числі
в такі які містять як було сказано
персональні дані як здобувачів освіти
так і працівників які
залучені до
реалізації освітньої послуги
коли ми говоримо про побудову будь-чого
що містить персоналку будь-чого на чому
стоїть пломба державної інформаційної
системи і особливо в умовах викликів
воєнного стану відразу ризиків безліч
насправді
можна констатувати що спочатку війни ми
знаходимося під перманентною
увагою народних кіберармій ворога і так
далі і інших подібних зловмисників
здійснюється ритмічні спроби зламати
систему заважати її працездатності це
досить і так далі тому в принципі але
знаєте це як метал Якщо по ньому багато
бити то з часом він загартується в
правильних технологічних умовах тому в
принципі оці постійні інсценуації вони і
загартували нас врешті-решт належним
чином і в нас Зараз побудована багато
ешелона система захисту Як апаратного
так і програмного яка
в тому числі як було сказано наприклад
колегами на попередніх сесіях
має також
елементи того захисту який на
національному державному рівні
декларується еталонним - це вимоги
державної служби спеціального захисту
спецзв'язку вірніше України Так звана
ксзі комплексна система захисту
інформації і так далі тобто Всі ці речі
е-е піднімали ставились на ноги саме в
відповідній екосистеми відповідні е-е
якби картині ризики Разом з тим
необхідно відзначити що
команда яка працювала вона
над реалізацію проекту вона включала в
себе багато суб'єктно таку
участь це було і Міністерство це були і
фахівці з
структурних підрозділів Міністерства це
як було сказано Це була Естонська
сторона
як мені дуже сподобався приклад Олексія
передати Привіт то я би теж хотів би
використати цей момент і передати Привіт
естонській стороні це гарна це команді
яка була залучена склала багато зусиль
до реалізації проекту це айлі Кай е-е
Маркус Рауль
нікого не забув
крабо-груп це сам виконавець це пані
Тетяна вам привіт І як ти в медіа Сергій
теж привіт все це команда стала на ноги
систему так щоб вона не була як в мене
одна колега любить говорити сферичною
лаковими тобто щоб це не був якийсь
ізольований простір автоматизації який
Потім після того як проект закінчиться
не буде Як сказано Було теж вдале слово
на попередній виступах систейний болт
тобто стійким що потім не буде зрозуміло
що державі з ним робити тому технічне
завдання писалося таким чином щоб
система була максимально однорідною
фактично було Теж вжито слово модульною
до тої яка уже впроваджена на
національному рівні
система icom система яка являється тісот
2.0 Ну можливо для когось абревіатури
незнайомі але по суті це система
управління освітою які вже
впроваджені в промислового експлуатацію
на національному рівні
підсумовуючи Я вже теж мене щось трохи
Мабуть я багато ефіру зайняв
підсумовуючи Я хотів би сказати що
викликів було багато як як її Кібер
загроз так і певних нормативних потому
що багато залучених цифровізації Він
знає що хотіти реалізувати наприклад
якусь інтерферабельність це одне діло а
реалізувати її це зовсім інше оскільки
там взаємодія з іншим державним
інформаційним ресурсом це шлях
нормативний це шлях технічний по
побудові конекторів спеціальних
протоколів обміну легалізації їх і так
далі ну це лише один з кейсів тому в
принципі робота було надзвичайно багато
багато що зроблено можливо на наступних
якихось своїх виступах під час даної
сесії я розповім окремі деталі з них
дякую
дякую Пане Андрію і давайте перейдемо
від національного рівня до регіонального
пані Наталі Можливо ви також
скористаєтесь нагодою передасте привіт
вашим Львівським колегам але я думаю
основна наше питання яке Ми хотіли би
сьогодні обговорити з вами це які все ж
таки на вашу думку успішні рішення у
сфері діджиталізації ви вбачаєте з точки
зору методистів будь ласка дякую ми
доєднувалися до тих палких привітань
колегам нашим з Львівщини але і почули
такі потужні інструменти деталізації
сгуст але реалії були такі
що станом на 2019-20 рік
50%
педагогічного колективу не мали навиків
навіть базового рівня централізації ось
з чого було розпочато з тренінгів
навчань базового навиків цифрової
інформації як створити електронну пошту
як працювати з хмарним середовищем на
це було
основне навантаження тому що як і
колективи які і працівники які були не
готові працювати в цьому середовищі
вбачали в певному мірі загрозу адже
студенти і здобувачі освіти які сиділи
перед ними були в цьому просторі
набагато краще
почувалися і
педагоги не бачили
можливостей реалізації себе і розуміння
Для чого мені це
це понад
два практично роки зайняло
роз'яснювальної роботи тренінгів
семінарів і розуміння які інструментарії
можна використовувати у освітньому
процесі системи освіти професійної
освіти зокрема курси з медіаграмотності
але в нашій системі також були такі
особистості які вже подолали бар'єри
базової і виходили на інші рівні Отже
треба було організовано і за дякуючи
підтримку партнерів Skills
систему навчань курсів найпотужніших
інструментарій деталізації цифрової
інформації чи курсів створення
медіаконтенту
акумулюючи власні знання кому малюючи
оцей досвід
які отримали
вже було налаштовано спільноти
освітянська до перших кроків до
створення
youtube-каналів YouTube до відеоконтенту
до навчальних матеріалів в нас є досвід
що
youtube-канал педагога
професійного навчання з закладу
перукарського має Понад мільйон
переглядів освітній контент тобто він є
затребуваний якщо це зроблений якісно
контент якщо він реалізований
на потребу
широкої-широкого інформації він є
сучасним
наступний рівень вже після створення
контенту ми були готові до
цього щоб створити онлайн-курс адже
не було україномовного освітнього
контенту якщо ще в системі загальної
середньої освіти
щось можна було переглянути то
професійна освіта цілком не мала такого
і телефонний дзвінок Юрія
Чи ви готові ми були готові до цього але
ми мали потужну підтримку Юрія зубана
команда юфо скіллсу Олексія ситника і
почали працювати з створенням контенту
амбітні плани але здавалося що ми вже
все знаємо можемо але воно цілком
створення освітнього
контенту в
відрізняється педагогічно від того як
проводити уроки коли
творча команда найкращих педагогів
майстрів професійної освіти Львівщини
зібралася які мають
певні регалії є мають переможці в
конкурсі в
з матеріалами А вони не вкладаються в
систему онлайн-курсу Для цього треба
цілком інший інструментарій це має бути
адаптовано швидко має бути якісний
візуальний контент і це було все
зроблено на базі закладів професійної
освіти зроблено фото відео
швидкі
інтерактивні тести і ми розширили
створення того цього онлайн контенту на
більш широку аудиторію тобто не тільки
здобувачі освіти які навчаються
дистанційно можуть ним користуватися а
також викладачі для того щоб
перевірити рівень знань цих а також він
цікавий є для будь-якої особи яка
цікавиться за напрямом хорика Тобто це
професії
кухарів-кондиторів сфери обслуговування
якщо хтось не заходивши на платформу
прошу переглянути можна для себе
власного використати певні навчальні
матеріали для
організації якогось своєї власної роботи
контент створений так що можна
прослідковувати і прогрес але це
величезна складна робота команди яка
могла її реалізувати завдячуючи ю
фоскілсі за підтримки її фоскілс дякую
дякую
пані Наталя дійсно була проведена дуже
грунтовна робота з розробки
онлайн-контенту і
більше 70 курсів уже завантажені на
платформу але продовжуючи все ж таки так
алексію
просто Наталя Так Почала типу якось
такої сильно мінорної ноти я така ж
злякався трохи типу там треба було не
знали як зареєструвати пошту не знаю я
коли почав з вами спілкуватись в 21-му
році ви вже все вміли типу в мене Ну
зараз я привідкрию при навчання Дійсно я
казав Павло Кузьмович Та я звернув увагу
більше на залізний компонент на те що ми
розробили там програмне забезпечення і
так далі але м'який компонент в рамках
програми теж дуже
велику частину займав і зокрема навчання
і вже зараз продовження Ну я просто
дивлюся як повиростали люди і вже зараз
ми збираємось їх додатково протестувати
визначити вузькі місця вузькі гепин де
комусь щось не вистачає і вже навчання
не широкомасштабні там для всіх аточку
вас спеціально вот конкретним групам
людей тобто от наступні навчання будуть
приблизно такого роду адресно кому що
треба там чуть підтягувати стосовно
професійної освіти онлайн я прям сильно
підтримую
Мені дуже хочеться хлопці А можна на
екран браузер вивести
можна
будь-який браузер профосвіта крапка
онлайн
якраз користуючись нагодою ми промотуємо
нашу розробле платформу в рамках
програми ufskills яку якою дійсно можна
користуватися не тільки здобувачам
професійно-технічної освіти але й також
викладачам внутрішнє переміщеним особам
а також 7 іншим стейкхолдером
зацікавленим сторонам
не бачу поки ще на екрані Можливо
пізніше з'явиться як можна знайти Так
дякую прекрасно показуйте нам
продовжуючи супер промотайте Трошки вниз
щоб люди побачили скільки там професій
оскільки
категорії за професією вибираєте в
кожній категорії знаходити курси вчитися
для себе в рамках навчального процесу
використовуєте під час своїх уроків
зокрема є окрема категорія для
директорів і педагогів закладів
професійної освіти підвищуєте
кваліфікацію проходити видно курс про
який сьогодні вже разів 50 сказали
робите ваші заклади більш привабливими
це все отут онлайн Дякую дуже що
показали
та Звідки так потрібно зареєструватися є
дві можливості зареєструватися у якості
викладача або зареєструватися у якочі
здобувача професійної освіти
останніх 30 секунд станом на сьогодні ті
курси які розробляли Наталя з колегами
ті курс які розробив Юрій зубан в рамках
програми faskills вони найкращі по
якості Тобто там є тренажери є
симулятори є в курси вбудовані
додатки А що застосунки застосунки з
доданою реальністю там Тобто кожна ви
проходите частинку курсу
доходити дивитись qr-код скануєте на
телефоні виконуйте завдання на телефоні
дуже круті але в мене для вас погана
новина вже зараз ми почали розробку
нових курсів за новими дев'ятьма
професіями з новим підрядником я не буду
говорити от і я думаю що ми зробимо ще
краще Так що є куди рости і Ну ми будемо
рости і ви з нами і будемо нові проекти
робити ще краще дякую Олексію а-а Тепер
я хотіла би передати слово пані е-е дачі
Вона представляє наших фінських колег
які також До речі долучилися до розробки
онлайн-курсів на платформі пані Даші які
на вашу думку є
найефективнішим
найефективнішими результатами або
напрацюваннями у сфері діджиталізації
будь ласка а Всім доброго дня а я
коротко розкажу про наші курси і наші
здобутки в рамках фінського консортіуму
ТОВ м'яч із розробила 20
короткострокових курсів я підтримки
відбудови України вона називається
А в нас є також програма тренінгу
керівників закладів професійно-технічної
освіти і також в нас є
програма для викладачів вона інформатиці
у нас складається з трьох модулів
англійської називається і
хочу сказати яка в нас була взагалі мета
цих короткострокових курсів Це була
мета була нашої забезпечити підтримку
навчанні конкретне професійним
компетентностям усіх бажаючих для
забезпечення потреб у робітничих кадрів
для відбудови України водночас програми
тренінгу для керівників закладів
профтехосіти та викладачів були
спрямовані на підтримку реалізації та
впровадження реформи профтехосвіти та
допомоги керівникам та викладачами
планування нових компетентностей та
навичок і як уже Сьогодні сказали що в
нас було зареєстровано більше 19,5
більше 19 тисяч учасників для участі в
навчанні і більше до нас з половиною
тисяч сертифікатів було видано в нашим
учасникам вони проходили курси або
модулі і після проходження у нас було
таке фінальне оцінювання і якщо вони
набрали відповідну кількість балів то
Вони отримували сертифікат а також
хотіла сказати що
цих курсів програм модулів нас були такі
найбільш популярні а й хоч виділити 5
таких це перший Це перша домедична
допомога Я думаю Я думаю зараз дуже
актуальний англійською він буде А потім
Це робота з дітьми вкризових ситуаціях
років
сприяння педагогічну добробуту та
соціального захисту родин уроків
отримали
робота на будівельному майданчику також
Думаю буду зараз дуже актуальним або
кіносайт та програма тренінгу кирюлків
закладів профтехосвіти Тобто це менше
стронінг
Дякую дальше
пані Ганно ми про вас не забули Я хотіла
би почути від вас які з педагогічної
точки зору ви вважаєте ефективними
рішеннями у сфері діджиталізації які
втілюються можливо і впроваджується уже
в вашому закладі про в техосвіти і ви як
викладач точних наук я знаю точно
надасте нам грунтовно цікаву відповідь
будь ласка Доброго дня Я
представляю такий досить специфічний
заклад професійної освіти Оскільки ми
ведемо підготовку
робітників там говорити Так дотичних до
айтігалузі
ті спеціальності І тому ми впроваджуємо
інформаційну комунікаційні технології
досить давно і навіть краще до
входження в цей проєкт ми мали достатню
кількість обладнання але всі ж розуміють
що обладнання
старі морально
технічно технічно забезпечення і
програми забезпечення зрозуміло що
завдяки програмі
хотілося б по-перше це все-таки
кращого забезпечення технічного тобто
технічними пристроями цифровими
пристроями не лише комп'ютер як всі
вважають
і різне обладнання і ми в рамках цього
проекту
досить таки багато його отримали ми
брали участь в багатьох
програмах маємо здобутки і відповідно
маємо
закладі за цих 4 майже 4 роки таке
поповнення дуже потужні такого
цифрового обладнання парку цифрового
обладнання і тому першим Я вважаю це ну
скільки ми тут ми розказували і не
говорили про діджиталізацію закладів
освіти певна перше місце ми би поставили
все-таки забезпечення цифровими
пристроями друге по-друге це звичайно
вдосконалення цифрових навичок педагогів
це і курси ми досить такі багато
курсів пройшли в рамках даного проєкту
інших також і звичайно вони всі майже
всі вони налаштовані на нас налаштовують
на удосконалення цифрових навичок да
роботи всіх ремем контентом створення
цифрових
робота з відео і так далі а
хотілося б звичайно ще доповнити якимись
курсами пана Олексіївна говорив про
точку таку роботу закладами і тому можна
хотілося били вже озвучити В нас дуже
багато є Запитів тому що ми маємо і 3D
принтери і камери і так далі а працювати
з ними нас ніхто не вчив і ми таким
методом знаєте
проб і помилок але все одно вважаємо що
неефективно його використовуємо і за
того що ми маємо Ну не маємо цих навиків
нема кому навчити
це друге Ну і
по-третє це звичайно от розвиток оцієї
національної платформи професійної
освіти це для нас стало знаєте таким
ну таким потужною та за допомогою у
використанні
цифрових технологій в освітньому процесі
також і педагоги нашого закладу залучені
до створення даних даного курсу зокрема
мульти професія монтажник
інформаційно-комунікаційного
устаткування
створений нашим нашим колегою але ми би
хотіли швидшого розвитку цієї платформи
бо вона нам потрібна
це ми розуміємо що одразу не може
з'явитися цей контент наповнення
працюючи люди але
ми хочемо такого більш стрімкого
розвитку щоб наповнюваність була дуже
швидка бо ми потребуємо вже сьогодні а
не три роки чекати поки повністю будуть
покриті всі курси всіма модулями але ми
дуже покладаємо великі надії на неї тому
що це безкоштовно і доступ ми маємо і
учні наші до таких цінних матеріалів які
нам дозволяють якісніше набагато вести
професійну практичну підготовку
це три таких кроки дякую пані гарно ви
вже зазирнули можна так сказати у
майбутнє і перейшли плавно до нашого
другого дискусійного блоку які
стосуються які наступні кроки
впровадженні діджиталізації Ми вбачаємо
з різних перспектив і я хотіла би
передати слово пану Олексію як з
адміністративної перспективи ви вбачаєте
наступні кроки у впровадженні
діджиталізації у системі адміністрування
та управління будь ласка
Зробіть будь ласка рожевий так
спеціально взяв щоб його здалеко було
видно
Дякую значить давайте все-таки не про
адміністративне бо я буду так на запити
колег відгукуватись
знову ж таки вам би хотілось щоб всі
матеріали за всіма професіями були вже
сьогодні
де взяти
але відповідь є Я приблизно півроку
годую
колег обіцянками що ми організуємо в
кожному регіоні медіала аби та і
створимо можливості для того щоб
проактивні педагоги самі могли
створювати найкращі освітній контент і
Вчора я отримав підтвердження що цей
проект такий буде так що дорогі колеги
рухаємось і будемо робити освітні конден
разом це щодо
розвитку платформи професійна освіта
онлайн щодо планів
dg-джиталізації
в адміністративній сфері та значить
Я просто думаю думаю вслух
одно Давайте так
[музика]
вступ реалізований практично повністю
вже ми завтра робимо великий вебінар
завтра о 10-ій ранку для всіх
адміністраторів є Де Бо закладів
професійної освіти і для
членів відбіркових комісій закладів
професійної освіти буде великий великий
вебінар про електронний вступ це проект
який ми реалізували разом з гарно і
відповідно
спеціалісти
ДП Інфоресурс будуть розказувати як
працювати з окремими модулями і так далі
але вже зараз ми бачимо
великий пакет напрацювання наступний рік
і відповідно з адміністративної точки
зору першим кроком це буде удосконале
будуть зміни до їди бо які будуть
стосуватися саме цього вступу щоб можна
було відпрацювати абсолютно всі сценарії
ті які виникають в операційній
діяльності закладів Ну щоб воно лише
в'їде бо і було щоб цей процес був
контрольований
відслідковуваним щоб ми бачили скільки
заявок подано за якою професією там і
так далі
другий теж величезний Ну прямо
величезний кусок роботи це наш так
званий третій етап розвитку еміс Давайте
я Андрія попрошу Хай йому про нього
краще розкаже Пане Андрію так переда
ю вам впровадження еміс можливо уже є
інформація як буде впроваджуватися еміс
на регіональному рівні та особливо
цікаве питання Я думаю про фінансування
тому що
проект еміс підтримувався програмою
fuskills А як надалі буде фінансуватися
та підтримуватися саме еміс будь ласка
я якщо можна
почну з дещо ширшого і потім звужуюсь до
того що було озвучено в запитання
перш за все стосовно цифровізації
управління
професійно-технічної освіти то тут ідуть
тенденції дещо уніфіковані і з іншими
сферами освіти і з тими підходами які до
нас доводяться командою цифровізації і
яка працює знову ж таки в тісному
симбіозі з міністерством цифрової
трансформації все більше і більше
впроваджується інстру років
бізнес-аналітики
bissingtelligence яка дозволяє
обробляти
великі набори великі масиви даних в
інтуїтивно зрозумілому для людини для
тої людини для того фахівця
яка наприклад неглибоко занурена в
механізми побудови вибірок з великих
масивів і так далі Тобто це по суті вже
напівготовий набір
індикаторів мультиплікаторів показників
структурованих згідно тих чи інших
параметрів деталізації які
доступні через там браузер як вітрини
даних в тому числі як вітрини даних які
містять елементи геокодування прив'язані
До території особливо з урахуванням тих
територій де ведуться бойові дії або
велися згідно
тих якби кодів катетг класифікації
адміністративно-територіальних одиниць
з урахуванням наказу відповідного
реінтеграції
Всі ці речі зараз активно в процесі
розробки впровадження пілотування а дещо
навіть використовується чи як було
сказано переді мною кількома спікерами
що
на жаль
мусимо констатувати що
біда для нас принесла певне вікно
можливостей яких раніше не було але цим
можливостями варто користатись досить
активно і не прогавити їх будемо
відвертими Тому зараз у нас в доступі
величезний потужний інструментарій наших
партнерів які благодійно в партнерстві
нашою державою відкривають для нас
коридори можливого використання їхніх
продуктів Я говорю не лише про якісь
загальновідомі речі там які стосуються
там інструментів Microsoft та Гугла і
так далі я говорю про речі там більш
Можливо навіть серйозні з елементами
штучного інтелекту певні
експериментальні і так далі тому
можливостей зараз з Державної аналітики
більше ніж було будь-коли Всі ці речі
активно впроваджуються активно
розгортаються да дійсно Є певні елементи
скажімо конфіденційності
цієї інформації не всю інформацію На
жаль зараз можна відкривати в ну в
відкритому доступі Вибачте за тавтологія
але якби це так і є
а те що
дезагрегований детальний масив даних в
тому числі індивідуальних має бути
основаних прийняття рішень то я думаю
для всіх це є абсолютно зрозумілим це в
міністерстві вже давно використовується
в реальних кейсах
з нами Павло Кузьмович який освітньо
субвенцію на ноги ставив розрахунок
моделювання з дрібних мікрод даних в
величезні мульти мільярдні потоки які де
загрегуються зверху донизу до кожного
засновника це знову ж таки
складні моделі логістики на основі
дрібних даних наприклад знову ж таки
чомусь в мене в голові як тільки я
згадував про якісь складний алгоритм
розподілу чимось ми не відразу Павло
Кузьмович поруч стоїть з цією задачею От
наприклад задача про розподілу Lego
наборів коли треба було на кожен там
наприклад клас розділити там певну
кількість наборів згідно параметра клас
не маючи базу даних це нереально
заробити маючи якісь зведені регіональні
плахти
ну це фіксованих даних нереально зробити
тільки дрібні реальні детальні дані є
можливість щось забезпечити в умовах
викликів військового стану це такі речі
як подвійний облік здобувачів освіти в
закладах звідки вони переміщаються і в
закладах де вони прикріплюються після
переміщення і так далі і тому подібне
але алокація розуміння кому треба
допомогти згідно якої черговості і лінії
пріоритетності Всі ці речі за рахунок
цифровізації
аналітики стають можливими Куди
рухаємося далі в плані розвитку цих
інструментів це ми рухаємося в першу
чергу в напрямку інтерферобільності з
іншими державними ресурсами
інформаційними системами чому
по-перше щоб не збирати що те що є тому
що це дуже погана практика На жаль вона
використовується часто щось збирається
незалежними каналами наприклад різними
відомствами але те ж саме
прикрой сумно Коли це в рамках одного
відомства відбувається
і так далі тому подібне є речі які
за рахунок цього інтерферабельності
досягається також це чистота даних тобто
уникнути механічних помилок впровадити
якісь алгоритмічні швидкі перевірки
валідація інформації про внесенні і так
далі тому в принципі Всі ці речі чим
далі тим більше зав'язуються
розгортаються в тому числі і з
використанням шини державного державної
взаємодії яка називається севдеїр
Трембіта до тої трембіти всі потужні
національні впровадження в промислового
експлуатацію системи державні
інформаційні уже підключення І лише
масштабується зони і невеличкий дотику
які активно впроваджуються знову ж таки
в промислово експлуатація Якщо говорити
про
цю автоматизацію яка являє собою
[музика]
систему управління освітою саме в
частині професійно-технічної освіти то
тут алгоритм її впровадження знову ж
таки абсолютно очевидний відбудуться
каскадні навчання
плавно
поступово з
знову ж таки з тим з використанням того
підходу що існуюча внесене не вноситься
ще раз воно доповнюється показники
додаткові збираються а не ті що вже десь
існують тобто якщо щось є вже в єде бо
то воно не буде ще раз паралельно
вноситесь з нуля незалежним потоком
кудись Воно з'їде бо буде
використовуватись для тої аналітики
і якщо потрібно наприклад організувати
якісь швидкий оперативний збір даних не
просто якби там масивам ексельок по
каскаду а
належним чином через автоматизовано
інформаційну систему то це буде
здійснено саме засобами системи
управління освітою яка в цій функції
собі якраз і
містить і вони це далі будуть
розвиватися розширюватись
стосовно
забезпечення
майбутнього і роботи підтримки
модернізації
розвитку відповідної системи то тут
Варто сказати що оскільки вона є Відразу
за концепцією яку
дякуючи міністерством досить швидко
узгодили зафіксували як такий коридор по
якому ми рухаємось то вона є модулем від
уже існуючої
впровадженої інформаційної системи icom
і будучи модулем цієї системи вона
органічно лягає в ті бюджетні програми і
Кошти які передбачені на розвиток ікона
тому не потрібно створювати під це щось
екстраординарно нове в плані лінії
бюджетної підтримки це можна Якби мені
досить природньо
якби інтегрувати в наявні коридори лише
знову ж таки планувати
заздалегідь як то класично відбувається
в тому числі з використанням
експертизи національної програми
інформатизації коли багато ешелону
узгоджується ці проекти з огляду на їх
цінність для держави і для цифровізації
в принципі ці всі речі досить сті саме
На мою думку є
трансфер програмного продукту відбувся
належним чином ніяких ризиків
в плані там
неповного або там частково відчуження
виключних майнових прав інтелектуальної
власності таких ризиків немає вони
абсолютно знівильовані все передано
повністю
[музика]
і з усіма технічними документаціями тому
в принципі
маючи розуміння архітектури програмного
апаратної ми абсолютно маємо розуміння
як це розвивати підтримувати якщо
говорити Вже такими якимись простими
словами докручувати там підчищати
підправляти ну так ну в принципі да
Ну я насправді
думаю їх збив Я вибачаюсь да тому Дякую
дуже Дякую Пане Андрію за такі за таку
такий довгий спіч
Ми згадали з вами
системи штучного інтелекту Насправді це
дуже цікава тема яку можна розглядати і
також з педагогічної точки зору і
давайте
[музика]
послухаємо що нам може розповісти пані
Даша як представник
фінського компоненту як відомо фіни
ідуть у ногу з часом
пані Даша які нові цифри є тренди в
освіті ви можете назвати і які загрози
та перспективи можуть мати штучний
інтелект доповнена реальність та інші
тренди в освіті будь ласка
дякую Так я думаю що ми всі бачимо що
процес навчання спинне змінюється як в
світі такі в Україні і Серед таких
основних трендів Я хочу Виділити це шту
проект це Віртуальна реальність
доповнена реальність та метод
а якщо ми кажемо про такі переваги та
можливості штучного інтелекту
віртуальної та неповнолі реальності Я
хочу назвати та виділити А це те що ці
симуляції які можна використовувати в
освіті вони захоплюючі вони імпресивні
вони економічноефективні а і також можна
сказати що в процесі такого навчання не
порушуються промисловий або виробничий
процес А навчання асимуляції симуляторах
воно безпечно для учнів немає жодного не
мають за них жодних ризиків на майже на
кількість спроб Наприклад якщо учень
учень практикується наприклад в ньому
він в цих трьох дії окулярах і вони
практикуються роблять скільки якщо вони
роблять помилку то викладач може
надати їм такий фідбек Ну тут вони
можуть отримати від нього та навчитися і
виправити свої помилки а також можна
сказати що це дуже такий економічно
ефективний варіант тому що не потрібно
Або можна зменшити витрати на подорожі
на обладнання на сировину навчання
становить стає маштабованим состояние
посталим та економічно ефективним і
також такі моменти які ще хочу виділити
особливо Зараз ми знаємо що учні деякі
деякі спеціальностей вони не можуть
отримати доступ до деяких об'єктів
важливої інфраструктури критичної
інфраструктури а і тому навчання на
симуляторах даємо таку можливість
навчатися та практикуватися А з точки
зору meteboards ми можемо сказати що Ну
метеоризм метасвіт Вона а-а має
потенціал трансформувати навчання
дистанційно об'єднувати викладачів та
учнів
і покращувати профтех освіти створювати
на мої можливості навчання протягом
усього життя
і згідно з науковими дослідженнями
застосування світу може покращити різні
результати навчання наприклад покращити
навички розуміння утримання або
збереження добутих знань А за учня учнів
концентрації уваги та збільшити їхню
мотивацію а також ми можемо Також я хочу
сказати що Ну взагалі така технологія
надає можливість навчатися у людей
викладачів та в основному до яких ви не
маєте фізичного взагалі ніякого доступу
це дуже здорово все дуже круто а Серед
таких основних загроз які можна
виділити ну окрім не знаю там варіанту
як в термінаторі
що дата машини
постануть можна сказати що наприклад
зараз ми всі бачимо що з використанням
chang GPT учні студенти дуже часто дуже
їм користуються І тому важко сказати чи
це була робота написана учнями по
студентам або
з допомогою штучного інтелекту а також
ну ми бачимо що це змінює взаємодію між
учнями та
викладачами і це Ну це має такий
негативний вплив а також є
[музика]
нерівномірність доступу до права
штучного інтелекту А І це може
посилювати розрив між більш безпечними
та більш ну менше забезпеченими учнями а
порушення приватності - це також така
велика проблема тому що
при використанні штучного інтелекту
збираються ваші дані персональні дані
учнів Вони можливо можуть збиратися без
згоди а по належного захисту цих даних а
отже Ну що це якщо це можна підсумувати
ми бачимо що є
такі деякі переваги або а також є
в навчанні в цифровому середовищі і
цьому і для того викладачі повинні
враховувати баланс між віртуальним
навчанням та навчанням в
форматі нашого дякую дякую пані Даша ми
прискорюємося і
наближаємося до завершення нашої
дискусії Я хотіла би абсолютно коротко
запитати У пані Ганни як з практичної
точки зору як викладач ви вбачаєте три
наступних кроків у впровадженні
діджиталізації в освітньому процесі будь
ласка пані Ганно
перше це
хотілося б ви все-таки перше Хотілося би
все-таки мати концепцію
цифрової трансформації освіти
затверджено і каже
2021 року нам обговоренні в міністерстві
так і обговорюється це перше тому що нам
потрібен вектор розвитку як для закладу
в сфері
діджиталізації
там шляхи розвитку способи вирішення
проблем які будуть
і так далі це перше друге - це
ви знаєте Ми вже вивчили дуже багато
досвіду в рамках цього проекту досвіду
європейських колег хотілося б вже
впроваджувати цей досвід і щось
змінювати
в своїй системі в нас була можливість
мати та навчальною поїздку в Фінляндію в
Центр професійної освіти Omnia і ми
взагалі були вражені і самою системою
освіти і багато чого побачили І ви вже
хотіли
би і також впроваджувати в своєму
закладі зокрема Ну і Третє - це перехід
від паперових наприклад обліку тобто від
паперів вже до електронних ресурсів ну
зокрема Наприклад ми би потребували
Хотілося би є журнали Але адаптовані
саме до професійної освіти щоб був
електронний щоденник кабінет учня саме
оцінювання
здійснювалась відвідування багато чого
Да там є школа моя школа багато чого є
але от адаптація саме До закладів
професійної освіти Хотілося би також
зменшити цей паперову
обіг папе
дякую пані гарно і хотіла би також
запитати у пані Наталі як з методичної
точки зору ви вбачаєте три наступних
кроків впроваджені діджиталізації на
регіональному рівні ми не розглядали що
такий момент який вже згадувався на
попередній панелі це навчання людей з
особливими освітніми потребами
деталізації думаю і симулятори
доповнена реальність це ті інструменти
які допоможуть навчати адаптувати дану
категорію людей освітнє середовище дати
їм можливості реалізувати себе в
подальшому житті Ми настільки глибоко
деталізувалися що нас Треба ще в тому
просторі захистити і то так
крутозахистити
це має бути постійно навчання з
кібербезпеки створення безпечного
простору тому що навіть Несвідомо
особа яка
зайде в це середовище може принести з
собою
ми вже згадували як вірус
ковід про який ми зараз трошечки забули
які розпочинався з одної людини і приніс
величезну нещастя в нашій
планеті Земля тому що такого не було в
цьому освітньому середовищі створеному
цифровому середовищі Він має бути чітко
чітко захищений і
цифрове освітнє середовище як цілісна
система
то це що згадували документообігу
аналізу
змісту освіти аналізу успішності для
того щоб можна було на будь-якому етапі
скорегувати з реалізувати якісь програми
побачити прогалине побачити пікі чи
максимум мінімуми в
рівнях оцінювання і вирівняти ті речі і
їх скорегувати і
це перспектива але перспектива має бути
контрольована людина дякую дякую пані
Наталю і я хотіла би запитати мого
технічного
працівника Артема чи у нас є запитання
від аудиторії
будь ласка чи є запитання від наших
учасників у залі
з нашої теми Я бачу запитань немає Від
онлайн аудиторії також немає запитань
тому що можливо Тема надзвичайно не так
добре розказувати чи так не зрозуміло
А час торт приїхав ясно ну це яка
цифровізація якщо там торт
давайте підведемо підсумки нашої
дискусії ми розглянули нашу тему з
різноманітних перспектив дуже ґрунтовно
розглянули з адміністративної та
управлінської сторони і виокремили такі
успішні інструменти як є кабінет
еміс інформаційну систему та
загальнонаціональну платформу з
методичної та педагогічної точки зору Ми
назвали знову ж таки якісною навчальний
контент обмін досвідом з нашими
іноземними партнерами
та багато інших цікавих речей Ми згадали
насправді штучний інтелект і чат GPT
яким можуть використовуватися в
навчальному в освітньому процесі Отже я
щиро вдячна
щиро вдячна за вашу увагу шановні гості
шановна онлайн аудиторія ми завершуємо
нашу дискусію і
пане Олексію
будь ласка Останнє слово з якими думками
ви йдете з нашої дискусії Тільки дуже
коротко будь ласка я буду коротко
дивіться Спочатку я хочу вам всім
подякувати я хочу подякувати
навчально-методичним центрам
Льоша привіт
Ага добре я тобі згадаю
ні справді ви величезний вклад я дякую
вам за те як ви відгукуєтесь да на
прохання так як ви включайтесь в процеси
департаменти точно так само пробачайте
будь ласка У мене все так у мене там
багато одночасно проектів і Мені треба
ваша допомога я буду писати вам втічати
буду хотіти з вас на вчора бігом але ми
робимо то перше я вам дякую а друге такі
доїдуть цього року не всім але
віртуальні окуляри
про які да от е-е
доїдуть в заклади і не бійтеся штучного
інтелекту у нас з вами буде все добре
хай бояться ті хто думають що Вони
зайняті зайняті інтелектуальною працею
от от їм варто боятися От у нас з вами
буде все раз прекрасно
я ціную вас люблю і обіймаю до нових
зустрічей
до нових зустрічей і
наостанок хотіла би запросити вас у нашу
лаунч зону де на всіх учасників офлайну
аудиторії чекає смачне частування та наш
торт будь ласка Запрошуємо а поки всі
виходять то я ще скажу два слова ви
можете виходить а я просто так вам
навздогін да нас уже не зупинити да
насправді
да хотілось би маленький Такий просто
вже так піднялись деякі питання вони так
в повітрі зависли стосовно наприклад
правомірності обробки персональних даних
здобувачів освіти в державних
інформаційних систем Якщо говорити про
міністерство освіти і науки України то
вона обробляє персональні дані
здобувачів освіти на виконання своїх
главних повноважень і це цей нюанс
обробки персональних даних він чітко
прямо зафіксований в законі Про зараз
персональних даних тому в принципі якщо
говорити мовою закону то ми на Ну ми це
як Міністерство освіти як розпорядник
даних Він навіть згоду від здобувача
освіти не мусить збирати про якщо це
робота з персональними данами
відбувається виключно в рамках
реалізації цих повноважень які е-е якими
оперує Міністерство освіти і науки
України що власне відбувається це перше
друге стосовно
електронного діловодства електронне
діловодство - Це абсолютно без
альтернативна майбутня автоматизація
будь-якої сфери освіти тому де бере
кретизація в плані того що папір
припиняється І лише показники
електронним автоматизованим способом
збираються це буде стовідсотково єдине
що ми маємо від мати гарантій ну на 100%
мати ту гарантію що ні граминки даних не
випаде з цього потоку І після того як ми
в тому пересвідчимось ми Я впевнений ці
папір весь скасуємо тому Дякую все дякую
Пане Андрію за ваше доповнення Я думаю
кого зацікавила особливо Дана тема може
поспілкуватися
протягом нашого
неофіційно нетворкінгу під час
частування і може продовжити саме цю
тему будь ласка
наші шановні учасники я вас запрошую до
нашого неформального нетворкінгу та
Дякую вам за увагу
всього найкращого
до нових зустрічей